Okay, so welcome to video number 25. We
will continue now with our trade idea
generation process. And we are still in
the quantitative phase. So we are
continuing going through our quantitative
processing. And this is video number four
of quant processing.
In the next two videos, we're going to be
looking at long ideas and short ideas and
the mechanics of the quant. So let's start
with the mechanics of long trade ideas.
Now, just to put everything into
perspective, so you understand exactly the
entire process and where everything fits
in, we have our leading indicator
leading indicator dashboard initially, and
this was for establishing a portfolio
bias. So we have our US leading
indicators. So US money markets, US
surveys, and US cyclical commodity prices,
denominated in US dollars. And then we
also have our international leading
indicators. So international money
markets, international surveys, and
international cyclical commodity prices.
So this is our macroeconomic leading
indicator dashboard. And our macro work
that we do as traders is to establish our
portfolio bias. So we covered an entire
section in the PTM video series on
macroeconomics, and how to establish that
portfolio bias. We also covered
foundations of portfolio bias.
We covered Foundations of Portfolio
Management with Chris Quill to introduce
you to concepts that are required in order
for you to appreciate why professional
traders use process in the way that we do.
We covered the fundamentals that pro
traders focus on also in the quantitative
phase at the microeconomic sector and
stock level when generating potential
trade ideas and introduce you to some new
ways of thinking about those fundamentals.
So, things are starting to come together
in the overall trade idea generation
process.
So, in the previous section, throughout,
when we were processing quant
fundamentals, we assumed that in the
background, we had already been through
our macroeconomic processing and we had
established a macroeconomic view.
And at any one moment in time, in the
future, when you are processing in the
quant phase, you will have a macro view
that's already in place and you will have
already established a portfolio bias.
Here, we are going to assume that you have
recognized that the world is in a cyclical
upswing, that you are forecasting real GDP
expansion with Fed target inflation intact
and that your portfolio bias is net long
and you want to be aggressively long
growth stocks in your portfolio.
Now, of course, this will change over
time.
However, at this stage, we need to make an
assumption here in order to continue
demonstrating how the process actually
works.
So, we are going to assume that we want to
have a net long bias in the portfolio and
what we are going to be concentrating on
in this video is earnings growth and,
specifically, earnings growth profiles.
So, we are going to have a net long bias
in the portfolio.
So, here we have our quantitative and
qualitative dashboard, which is our
microeconomic filtering process in both
quantitative and qualitative metrics when
we are generating trade ideas.
So, we are marrying up the macroeconomics
and the microeconomics to generate
potential trade ideas and you will be able
to use the macro and the micro, so the
quantitative and qualitative dashboards
going forward as process checklists
throughout your trade idea generation
processes.
So, now, as mentioned, we are still at
this stage in the quantitative phase and
we will be looking now in this video at
the actual mechanics of how you go about
in filtering the data and essentially
drilling down throughout the US stock
market to get potential long ideas.
So, we are going to be looking at best
practices to isolate positive outliers.
Now, also included in this video is going
to be a demonstration from Chris Quill
with an Excel lesson on how to implement
these processes both practically and
efficiently.
So, when you are doing this yourself, you
can go through the processes and get to
very quick answers in identifying positive
outliers.
Now, never forget, in the background, in
your minds, you have to always be thinking
of the overall pro trader systematic
framework.
So, again, we are split into two areas
here, the theory and the implementation of
where we are right now is in the
quantitative processing phase of
fundamentals.
We will, of course, come on to the
qualitative phase later and qualitative
processes.
But just remember for the moment, the
overall pro trader systematic framework
and where we are sitting right now in
fundamentals.
It is the most important part of the trade
idea generation process.
And if you recall, pro traders are putting
a 80% to 90% weighting on the importance
and the amount of work that they're doing
split between fundamentals and technicals
or timing.
So, timing comes next.
So, timing comes next, but it is only 10%
to 20% of our overall work and importance
of the overall process.
So, fundamentals are the most important,
80% to 90%.
But both fundamentals and timing have to
be seen within the restrictive parameters
of opportunity set and volatility.
What do we want as traders?
We want the biggest amount of opportunity
set or amount of stocks possible.
And we, of course, want volatility.
Volatility is a trader's best friend and a
portfolio manager's worst enemy.
You will have learned this in the IPLT
video series.
If you haven't taken the IPLT video
series, I would encourage you to do so
because this is how everything fits
together.
So, our theory part of the overall pro
trader systematic process is essentially
the research and work that we are doing
mostly on fundamentals to generate trade
ideas within the parameters of volatility
and opportunity set.
And, of course, once we generate a trade
idea, a trade idea then becomes a real
position where we are taking a real money
position in our trading accounts.
So, the second stage of the overall pro
trader systematic framework is when we
actually implement our ideas that have
been generated by work and research.
And when we take positions off, they're
either going to be winners or losers and
we're going to generate an overall track
record and we're going to have trader
metrics or statistics as to how effective
we are as traders.
Now, for this video, we are in the
bottom-up fundamental area in the
quantitative bottom-up phase.
So, quantitative bottom-up process.
We are obtaining micro views based on
fundamentals.
So, we're making this assumption that we
have our long, our net long portfolio bias
in the background and we are going to be
looking at identifying potential long
ideas based on earnings growth profiles.
In later videos in the PTM video series,
so later within the trade idea generation
process, we will be looking, obviously, at
qualitative processes, which are the
numbers and the qualitative information
with a company or a stock behind the quad.
So, what is behind the quad?
What is behind earnings growth?
What is behind revenue growth?
What is behind valuation?
That is another level that's deeper in our
work that we will be covering later.
But for now, we're covering earnings
growth to make sure that when you're
processing, you're doing all the right
things and not getting into bad habits.
So, over the years, we've seen this time
and time again at ITPM, even from students
who have gone through and understood all
of our teachings and understood all of our
processes, but they always continue to
look for the shortcuts.
The shortcuts are bad habits, guys.
So, one of the worst habits that you can
possibly have, even if you have the right
information and understand everything that
ITPM is teaching you.
One of the worst habits is going through a
quantitative process where you're
attempting to do box ticking exercises,
such as looking at earnings growth and
implicitly making the statement through
your actions that you've found a stock
that has high earnings growth and a high
price earnings ratio relative to its peer
group.
And then you miss all of the extra work.
You miss all the interpretation.
And then you believe that because you've
done that, you've just rearranged some
data and information in a spreadsheet that
it becomes an automatic trade idea.
This is wrong.
You don't know anything about the stock.
You don't know anything else about it.
You know nothing at this stage.
So, if you go and put a position on, when
you've done that work, you're going to
have absolutely no conviction in your
position and the idea is incomplete.
It's way incomplete.
So, it is far at this stage, far from
being an actual trade idea.
So, this is wrong, guys.
Please do not do this.
You're looking for shortcuts.
This is the lazy retail trader default
situation where you're thinking that if
you rearrange the data in a spreadsheet,
you just filter for high earnings growth
at high PE, that the stock that's at the
top of the table becomes an automatic
lock.
It obviously doesn't.
There's a lot more work to do.
The next bad habit here is only looking at
familiar and comfortable blue chip names
that you've heard of in the media that are
very large market cap, which essentially
have low volatility.
So, they offer low risk and therefore low
opportunity.
So, you end up being invested in a market
cap space, which is too high.
So, the risk reward or the opportunity is
not skewed in your favor.
So, it's time to start thinking of
earnings growth in the context of market
cap.
So, in the context of mega cap market cap
stocks, large cap market cap stocks, mid
cap and small cap.
So, the absolute number for earnings
growth absolutely matters to traders.
So, imagine for a moment you're going
through your filtering processes and you
find a large cap stock within a sector
that you know, you've heard of the company
before.
So, naturally, for some reason, people
tend to gravitate to familiarity.
So, imagine you're in this situation and
you have a large cap stock in a sector
that you recognize and it's outperforming
its peer group, but it has 6% earnings
growth.
The absolute number is still very low.
Absolute earnings growth of 6% for a
trader is just boring.
Now, of course, it could be an investment
for the long term, but we are traders.
A stock that is a large cap stock with
only 6% earnings growth to us is not a
trade.
It is not a trade with a one to three
month time horizon.
You need earnings growth with catalysts
that will move the price in a meaningful
way in the next one to three months, 20 to
60 trading days.
Where is this more likely to happen in the
stock market?
It's much more likely in the mid cap
space.
This is where we're going to find a large
opportunity set with volatile
outperformers relative to the sector with
high earnings growth.
So, with, say, 30% plus earnings growth,
and they can potentially beat to the
upside in a meaningful way with multiple
catalysts in between.
So, you have to stay away from these two
bad habits when you're processing, looking
for potential long trade ideas.
Stay away from the bad habit of only box
ticking for earnings growth and PE and
just taking high numbers and then thinking
that automatically becomes a trade idea.
That's wrong.
You have to do a lot more work than that.
Stay away from the next bad habit, which
is looking only at comfortable, familiar
blue chip names that have low volatility.
You need to get into the good habits of a
trader.
Good habits of a trader, please.
So, let's start thinking here about market
cap as a filter within the mechanics of
potential long trade ideas.
A mid cap that has a market capitalization
of, say, $5 billion has more potential to
double and double quickly than, say, a
mega cap that has a $40 billion plus
market capitalization.
As traders, we would much rather be long a
mid cap stock that has a $5 billion market
capitalization with, say, 30% plus
earnings growth for the next year and the
year after versus being long a $50 billion
mega cap stock that only has 12% earnings
growth.
For example, for example, for the next
year and the year after.
The $5 billion market cap stock, the mid
cap, has a lot more potential upside than
the mega cap stock at $50 billion.
So, $5 billion with, say, 30% plus
earnings growth has way more potential
upside in a quicker period of time than
the mega cap stock,
the $50 billion stock with, say, 12%
earnings growth.
Remember, in the stock market, money likes
growth and dislikes a slowdown in growth
and even worse, a contraction.
So, as traders, when we are going through
the mechanics of identifying potential
long trade ideas, we are naturally going
to gravitate towards growth and
volatility.
Why?
Because we need growth and we need the
money and the market on our side and they
like growth.
That will drive price to the upside.
Additionally, we want volatility.
We want volatility.
We want to be operating where we have
volatility and therefore risk and
opportunity that provides us with the
chance to make outsized returns.
So, in the US stock market, there are
actually definitions for market
capitalization.
Micro caps in the US are less than $1
billion market cap.
Small caps in the US are defined as market
caps between $1 billion and $3 billion.
Mid caps in the US are defined as having
market caps between $3 billion and $10
billion.
And mega caps are defined as any stock
that has a market capitalization of $40
billion and above.
So, because we are traders and not
investors, you have to start thinking in
terms of your processes about what you
want to be long and what you want to be
short.
And therefore, you are going to naturally
gravitate to certain areas of the market.
With your long ideas, you need to start
concentrating on the $3 billion to $10
billion mid cap space.
And for your short ideas, you need to
concentrate on the $20 billion plus market
cap space.
So, within large caps and within mega
caps.
Why do we do this as traders?
Well, because we like earnings growth and
we like volatility.
And in the mid cap space, earnings growth
is generally greater than in large and
mega caps.
So, you have to start using market
capitalization as a filter as well as
price earnings ratio, earnings growth and
peg ratio.
And really, what you're actually doing
here is you're using volatility as a
filter.
So, the opportunity and risk of a
potential idea.
And the mid cap space is ideal for the 20
to 60 day time horizon in terms of
volatility.
You will have learnt this in the IPLT
video series if you've been through that.
But also, in the mid cap space, the
companies themselves, their business
models are actually proven.
So, if you ask yourself the question,
well, why don't we look at small caps and
micro caps?
Well, the small caps and micro caps in
terms of the evolution of their business
models, the vast majority of them, their
business models are not yet proven.
So, mid caps that possibly used to be
small caps or micro caps have now grown to
become mid caps.
And in the mid cap space, their business
models are proven and the companies are
still in the growth phase.
So, it's the best of both worlds.
We get the growth and we get the
volatility and we also get predictable,
proven business models.
So, there's not as much noise as in small
caps and micro caps.
We actually have meaningful fundamentals
that we can understand and do work on.
Now, when we are going through our
mechanical processing of the quant and
we're identifying positive outliers in the
mid cap space,
we are always looking first, as we've
mentioned in previous videos, at price
earnings ratio and earnings growth
percentage.
Earnings growth is usually, but not in all
cases, the most important factor and is
going to drive high price earnings ratio
and PEG ratio.
Earnings growth will most of the time
drive valuation.
So, when you're going through your quant
processing phase, you're going to find a
lot of the time that when earnings growth
is high, this usually means that the
market is willing to pay a premium for
that growth.
And you will see this as evidenced by a
high PE and PEG ratio.
Now, this is a best practice
identification process when we're looking
for the classic long stock setup.
What's up?
So, when we're looking at growth names, of
course, there are other types of long
ideas for different types of market
conditions and portfolio bias.
But when you're learning and you're
setting out on the journey of learning how
to identify trade ideas and potential
longs, it's important that you first learn
the classic long idea, bread and butter
identification process or setup.
We are going to look later.
We are going to look later as we go
through the trade idea generation process.
We're going to look later at different
types of longs as well.
But for now, the most important thing is
to learn the bread and butter, the
majority default long growth
identification process.
And as a reminder, we are going where the
juice is, where the juice in the market
exists because we are traders.
We look at the US stock market and we have
2200 plus available stocks to us to
potentially generate in terms of trade
ideas and end up taking positions in.
We have different types of sectors which
fall into the categories of cyclicals and
defenses.
And we have different types of stock
dynamics, different types of stocks.
We have growth stocks.
We have X growth stocks.
And we also have value stocks.
As traders, we are going to lean and be
attracted to, on the long side, growth
stocks naturally.
And not only just growth stocks, but
stocks that provide us with opportunity,
with upside and outsized returns.
So we are going to gravitate towards
stocks that are positive outliers in the
sector.
So they're going to outperform the sector
and outperform the market in a positive
GDP environment.
Now we do have a download that accompanies
this video.
If you go to the downloads area, you'll
find the downloaded file, earnings growth
profiles for longs.
Inside the file, once you've downloaded
it, you're going to see in there the
earnings growth profiles that we look at
through a long lens.
And we're going to look at these through
the rest of the video now.
But first and very quickly, you have to
understand the valuation backdrop, which
is the ideal setup in addition to earnings
growth long profiles that we look for.
So if you think about price earnings
ratios and you think of the first period
and the second period.
So the first period being the current year
and the second period being next year.
So we have PE1 and we have PE2 and PE1 is
simply the current stock price of the
stock divided by the forward estimate of
EPS for the current year.
And PE2 is the current stock price divided
by forward looking EPS for the following
year, next year.
So the ideal setup that we want to see
from a stock is obviously to see EPS
growing.
So in the second year, if we divide the
current stock price with EPS of the second
year, we're going to get a lower PE ratio
than the first year because we're dividing
by a higher number.
So the EPS is higher in period 2,
therefore using the same stock price for
period 1 and period 2, the PE ratio in
period 2 is going to be lower than period
1.
Additionally, what we want to see is in
both periods, the PE ratio for the stock
is higher than the PE ratio for the
sector.
Now, how do we work out the sector PE
ratio?
Well, we need a mean average EPS estimate
for the sector.
And we do this by adding up all of the EPS
numbers in each period, PE1 and PE2, and
then dividing by the amount of stocks in
the sector.
When we see in both periods that we have a
higher PE premium to the sector from the
stock, it means we have confirmation of
the valuation that the market is pricing a
premium of the stock in valuation terms
versus the sector.
This gives us evidence that the market
likes the stock and is prepared to pay for
the growth and pay a premium to the
sector.
What you will also notice is that the PE
ratio in period 2 for the sector is lower
than in period 1, which means the average
earnings per share of the sector is
increasing from period 1 to period 2.
Earnings per share is increasing for the
stock as well over the 2 periods, but the
stock trades on a premium to the sector
for both periods.
So, this is the ideal valuation backdrop
when we're processing, looking for long
ideas when we're doing our quant
processing.
So, we have a stock in the sector that is
trading in period 1 and period 2 on a
premium to the sector, and it has higher
EPS in period 2 versus period 1.
Now, in tandem with this, the ideal
situation when we're doing our quant
processing and looking for long ideas, the
ideal setup is not only to have a PE
premium on the stock versus the sector in
period 1 and period 2,
where we have EPS going higher, what we
also want is the ideal earnings growth
setup.
So, we have our two periods, earnings
growth 1, which is the percentage increase
in EPS from period 0 to period 1.
So, EG1 percentage, the percentage
increase in EPS from last year to current
year.
So, EG0, last year's EPS that is reported,
and the percentage increase to period 1,
which is an EPS forward-looking estimate,
and the percentage increase from 0, last
year to period 1.
And what we want to see from EG1
percentage is that the company's earnings
per share is growing at a faster rate than
the sector earnings growth percentage
increase rate.
So, you'll also notice here as well that
the sector is growing positively, so the
earnings growth with the sector average is
actually growing as well.
So, in an ideal backdrop, what we want to
see is that the sector earnings growth is
growing faster in EG2 versus EG1.
And then when you have a look at the stock
itself, you want to see in earnings growth
2 that the rate of growth for the stock is
faster in earnings growth 2 versus
earnings growth 1.
But it's also higher than the sector rate
of growth in EG2 period.
So, the earnings growth for the stock is
faster than the sector in both periods,
but for the stock itself, it is faster in
the second period versus the first period.
And what we call this, when we just look
at the stock itself, so in absolute terms,
we call it sequentially positive earnings
growth momentum.
And when we look at it in comparison
relative to the sector, we call it
sequentially positive above sector average
earnings growth momentum.
The easiest way to think of this is that
the stock, the company itself, its
earnings are growing faster than the
sector in both periods.
And in period 2, the rate of increase for
the company itself is faster in period 2
versus period 1.
So, we have earnings growth momentum.
So, this is the ideal scenario that we are
looking for for our earnings growth
profile for long trade ideas with the
backdrop of the ideal setup for valuation
for price earnings ratio.
Now, there are obviously other earnings
growth profiles that are available to all
traders and indeed all investors.
Now, we are going to look at 10 different
earnings growth profiles in absolute and
relative terms to the sector.
And it's just important for clarity
purposes to understand that as traders,
what we are really interested in from a
momentum perspective, because we're not
investors, we're not looking at holding on
to positions for years.
We're looking at 20 to 60-day time
horizon, and we need momentum.
So, when we're looking at profiles,
earnings growth profiles, through a long
idea lens, a long idea processing lens,
what we are interested in, in the first
place, is having positive EPS.
And then on top of that, we want positive
earnings growth.
Now, we're going to look at 10 cases here,
where we look at different earnings growth
profiles, both in absolute and relative
terms.
Eight of them, we have positive EPS.
So, we can have positive EPS, and we can
have negative EPS.
So, negative is when the company is
loss-making.
Positive is when the company is making
profits.
negative EPS.
And then on top of that, we are looking
for evidence of earnings growth percentage
momentum.
So, we have our first case of an earnings
growth profile.
This is the one we have looked at already,
which is the sequentially positive
earnings growth momentum, the ideal
scenario.
So, we have in the first period, current
year, forward-looking estimates of EPS.
We have positive EPS, we have positive
EPS, and we have earnings growth above
sector average in the first period.
In the second period, we have more
positive earnings growth than in the first
period.
And we are above the sector average,
again, in period two.
So, this is the ideal scenario.
The next best thing is case number two,
where we have, again, the companies making
money.
We have positive EPS, but we have positive
above sector average earnings growth for
EG1.
And then in period two, EG2, we have
positive earnings growth for the company
that's the same or around the same level
as it was in period one.
But again, we are above the sector average
even in period two.
And the next best earnings growth profile
after that is our case number three, which
is positive earnings growth percentage
that is above sector average in period
one.
So, yes, of course, the company is making
money, we're making profits, and the
earnings growth in EG1 is above sector
average.
And in the second period, the earnings
growth percentage for the company itself
is less positive than in the first period,
but it's still above sector average.
Now, these are our three most favourite
earnings growth profiles when we are
looking for logs.
Because what it does is it provides us
with evidence that the market likes the
stock better than the sector from a
valuation perspective.
So money is liking the stock, so money is
liking the stock, so we have the market on
our side.
And in the background, we have evidence of
either earnings growth momentum that's
sequentially positive, or positive EPS
growth that is higher than the sector.
So the valuation and the earnings growth
is supportive that the market likes the
stock better than the sector.
And it's important to remember here, just
so there's no confusion.
The PE profile that is ideal is still
intact, even in case number two and case
number three.
Because for example, in case number two,
where in period one, we have positive
above sector average earnings growth.
So what we're looking at is a percentage
number, and then a percentage number again
in the second period.
So even though the EPS growth is positive
and the same in percentage terms, the EPS
itself is still going higher.
Which means the second period PE ratio
using today's stock price will still be
lower than period one.
Now, once we start getting out of the top
three earnings growth profile
characteristics, we start to struggle as
traders to justify why we would have these
positions fundamentally.
Why we would even generate them as an
idea, even to begin with.
So let's have a look at case number four,
five and six.
So case number four, positive EPS, that's
at the sector average in both periods.
Well, in that situation, by default, we
would probably have the opportunity cost
here to simply own the sector.
And we're looking at this through a long
idea lens.
As traders, we obviously want better than
this.
We can go to multiple other sectors and
get sequentially positive earnings growth
momentum in case one.
Or even get earnings growth profiles from
case number two and case number three.
So case number four, we can do better than
this.
Why would we want to do that as traders
when we can go into other sectors and we
can find case number one, two and three,
where we have better fundamentals for a
long idea.
Case number five is positive EPS growth
that is below sector average in period
one.
And in period two, positive EPS growth
that is at or above the sector average.
Even in this situation, we have
opportunity cost to simply owning the
sector because in the first period of the
current year, forward looking EPS growth
forecasts are below sector average.
Again, we obviously want better than this
case.
And in case number six, in period one, we
have positive EPS growth that is below
sector average.
And then in the second period, we have
positive EPS growth, but that is below
sector average again.
So even worse, we have a very, very strong
relative opportunity cost to simply own
the sector here.
Again, we want better than that case.
So let's have a look at these earnings
growth profiles visually.
We've already seen the first one, our
first case, which is sequentially positive
above sector average earnings growth
momentum.
With our PE backdrop, our valuation
backdrop, this is the ideal setup
fundamentally when we are long idea
processing as traders.
Next up was our second case where we have
positive earnings growth, so positive
earnings growth percentage in EG1.
So in period one, that is higher than the
sector average.
And then in period two, for the stock
itself, we have the same level or around
the same level of earnings growth
percentage for the stock as in period one.
But it's still higher than the sector
average.
And notice as well, that the sector
average is going up.
So in all of these cases, we have a sector
tailwind.
And remember, in the background, we have a
positive GDP environment.
Let's have a look at our third case.
Our third case is where we have in the
first period, the stock having higher
earnings growth.
In percentage terms than the sector.
And of course, the sector is positive
earnings growth percentage as well.
And then in the second period, the stock
has lower earnings growth, but still
positive and still higher than the sector
earnings growth,
even though the sector earnings growth is
positive as well.
And the sector earnings growth is higher
than in the first period, which means
again, we have a sector earnings growth
tailwind.
And we have positive earnings growth
that's higher for both periods for the
stock itself.
Now, once we start moving out away from
these types of profiles, this is where
things start to become non-optimal for
traders.
So this is our case number four, where we
have positive earnings growth for the
stock in both periods.
But it's at all around the sector average.
And I've purposely put on this chart in
the second period, a slightly higher bar
for the stock in terms of EG2 percentage
versus the sector EG2 percentage.
You'll see that the sector comes in at 16%
and the earnings growth profile for the
stock in period two comes in at 17%.
A 1% difference really is no difference.
It's basically the same.
So when we have this type of situation,
it's not ideal.
We'd be probably better off on a risk
adjusted basis, just owning the sector.
And when we're looking for long ideas to
potentially go into our portfolio, our job
as traders is not to own the sector.
Our job as traders is to do way better in
our returns than the sector average.
We are seeking here to identify positive
outliers in the sector.
Next up is our fifth case, where in period
one, we have positive earnings growth, but
it's below the sector average.
And then in the second period, positive
earnings growth, that's either at or above
the sector average.
And on the screen here, we've depicted it
as above sector average.
So in this scenario, yes, over a period of
two years, we do get a swing in EPS growth
from the stock.
That's more positive in the second period
than in the first period.
And yes, it's higher than the sector in
the second period, but it's lower in the
first period.
So over a two year period, the earnings
growth of the stock relative to the sector
is pretty much the same.
This is not an ideal situation for
traders.
Again, on a risk adjusted basis, we would
probably be better off just owning the
sector for a long time.
But as traders, that is not our job.
We're looking for positive outliers and
we're looking to crush our returns.
Next up is our case number six, where for
both periods, the earnings growth for the
stock is below the sector average, even
though the earnings growth is positive in
both periods.
And this is just not anywhere near ideal
for us at all.
We'd be way better off just owning the
sector.
And again, that is not our job.
So these are our first six earnings growth
profiles, but we're looking at them
through a long idea processing lens.
Now let's have a look at our next four,
which we split up into two parts.
So seven and eight, case number seven and
eight, we have negative earnings growth,
but we still have positive EPS.
So the company is loss making in the case
number nine and case number 10.
In cases number seven and eight, EPS is
still positive, but there's negative
earnings growth in the first period.
So let's start with case number seven.
We have positive EPS, but we have negative
earnings growth and it's below sector
average.
In the second period, we have positive
earnings growth and it's below sector
average.
Obviously not optimal for traders.
We have opportunity cost to simply owning
the sector.
In case number eight, we have positive
EPS, but we have like in case number
seven, we have negative earnings growth.
That's below the sector average in period
one.
But in period two, we have positive
earnings growth that is either at or above
the sector average.
Now, how do we characterize this type of
earnings growth profile?
Well, we characterize this as what we call
in the industry a turnaround story.
And for traders, because of the swing, the
magnitude of the swing from negative
earnings growth to positive earnings
growth, being above the sector average in
the second period, but coming from below
the sector average in the first period,
the magnitude of that move gets our
attention.
So this could be worth looking at a
turnaround story as a different type of
trade for our portfolio versus the classic
long setup.
So this is a different type of setup that
as traders, we could look at.
Our next case, case number nine, is also a
turnaround story, and it has even bigger
magnitude move, because in this situation,
the company is loss-making to begin with
in period one.
And in EG1, they have negative earnings
growth, that's below the sector average.
And then moving into period two, they have
the biggest swing from negative EPS and
negative earnings growth, so loss-making
and negative earnings growth below sector
average, to having positive earnings
growth above the sector average.
So this is a very big move in EPS.
This is the widest move we can have.
It's another turnaround story.
And for traders, it may be worth looking
at, again, as a different type of trade
for the portfolio.
But these types of EPS growth profiles,
case number eight and case number nine,
the turnaround stories, it does come with
a caveat.
It is very opportunistic and very
dangerous at the same time.
So it's high risk, high reward, and high
risk, potential high loss.
And then we have our tenth case, which is
where in period one, the company has
negative EPS, the company is losing money,
but they also have negative earnings
growth.
So that's below sector average, and then
in the second period, we essentially have
the same situation.
But the company gets either at or below
sector average earnings growth.
So negative earnings growth in period two,
like in period one, but in the second
period, it's either at or below the sector
average.
This just isn't worth looking at at all.
Now, from a classic kind of portfolio
management perspective, this is the type
of earnings growth profile that could
provide investors with a hedge to a high
quality long idea in the same sector.
However, we are not investors and we are
not in the hedging game.
We want to be, as traders, long, great
stocks that go up a lot.
And we want to be short, terrible, crappy
stocks that go down a lot.
We always should be looking to optimize.
So we do not go into positions, into long
positions, and then put short hedges
against them.
We don't need them because, as traders, we
should be always looking for shorts that
are actually going down, looking for bad
stocks.
So we'll learn about this in the next
video.
We want to be keeping volatility high in
the portfolio and correlation as low as
possible.
And we want to be avoiding hedges wherever
We would much rather be short cross sector
than intrasector and shorting stuff just
for the sake of shorting it to have a
hedge.
And shorting something in the same sector
just because it's in the same sector and
it looks bad on paper isn't the way we
want to go.
We would much rather be cross sector and
shorting genuinely bad stocks that are
going to go down rather than looking for a
generic hedge in the same sector.
And when looking for shorts, we should be
looking at much higher market cap.
And as mentioned, more of this will come
later in the next video.
Now let's have a look at cases 7, 8, 9 and
10 visually so we fully understand them.
Case number 7, which is our negative
earnings growth.
Earnings growth.
That's below sector average in the first
period.
But remember, this case still has positive
EPS.
So we have the negative below sector
average earnings growth in period one.
And then in period two for the stock, we
have positive earnings growth percentage,
but it's below the sector average.
In this situation, this type of earnings
growth profile, when we are processing in
our quant for longs, is pretty useless to
us as traders.
We are not optimizing.
Our next case is case number 8, which is
our first turnaround story, where again,
this company has positive EPS.
But in the first period, they have
negative earnings growth.
That's below the sector average.
Then in the second period, they have
positive earnings growth.
That's around the sector average.
So what's happening to this company is
that they're having a year where their
earnings growth is negative.
And then they're turning it around and
it's going positive.
And it's forecasted to be somewhere around
the sector average in the second period,
year two.
We would define this as a turnaround
story.
Now, our next case, case number nine, is
our turnaround story on steroids.
So it's our turbo turnaround story.
This is the earnings growth profile where
the company is actually loss making.
They have negative EPS and they have
negative earnings growth that's below
sector average in the first period.
And then in the second period, they have a
massive turnaround in EPS that goes from
negative EPS to positive EPS.
And they have extremely high positive
earnings growth that's way above the
sector average.
So these turnaround stories, case number
eight and case number nine, because of the
magnitude of these moves in earnings
growth, they do get our attention.
And they could be quite interesting to us
as traders as different types of long
earnings growth profiles that we could
potentially have in our portfolio to
diversify our earnings growth profiles and
to diversify the types of long trades that
we have in the portfolio.
We will be discussing this in subsequent
videos further in the video series.
Next up is our case number 10, where
again, like case number seven, this is
pretty useless to us.
But in this situation, the company is loss
making.
So they have negative EPS in the first
period.
Their earnings growth is negative and
below the sector average.
And in the second period, their earnings
growth is negative and it's either at or
below the sector average.
In this situation, the stock may look like
a short versus a long idea in the same
sector.
But we want to move away as much as
possible from having interest sector
spread trades on within the portfolio.
We would much rather go to another sector
and find a genuinely terrible crappy stock
that's going to go down.
So we get the cross sector element in our
portfolio in terms of the overall risk of
the portfolio.
So these are our 10 earnings growth
profiles that we look at and we take
actions on to optimize as traders.
In this video, we've looked at the
mechanics of long trade ideas.
In the next video, we'll be looking at the
mechanics of short trade ideas.
But let's close the loop here on long
trade ideas.
We always want to be optimizing and we
want to be making sure that we have
valuation and earnings growth that is
evident that the market likes the stock
that we're looking at when we're
attempting to identify positive outliers
in the sector.
So if you think back to the tables that we
looked at in previous videos where we
mapped out an entire sector and we had all
of our metrics that we look at in the
spreadsheet where we had price earnings
ratio, earnings growth and we had peg
ratio and market capitalization.
Now, for long ideas, we will have a market
capitalization filter.
We will always lean towards mid caps.
We are looking in that $3 to $10 billion
market cap space.
What we will also filter for is what we
filter for for long ideas in our first
step, like we did in previous videos.
First, we will filter for PE and we will
then filter for earnings growth both in
period one and in period two.
And what are we looking for in the ideal
situation?
We are looking for PE on a premium to the
sector in period one and then PE on a
premium to the sector in period two.
But the PE is lower in period two than in
period one, both for the stock and both
for the sector.
For both the stock and the sector, this is
evidence that EPS is going higher.
And for the stock itself, it is evidence
that the market likes the stock and
prefers the stock and pays a premium to
the sector.
Additionally, we will filter for earnings
growth percentage.
And what we want to see in the ideal
scenario is for the stock to have positive
earnings growth that is higher than the
sector in period one.
And then in period two, the stock earnings
growth in period two is higher than its
earnings growth in period one and higher
than the sector.
Additionally, we want to see that earnings
growth in the sector overall is actually
trending higher as well.
So, for our case one, our ideal earnings
growth profile for long-idea quantitative
processing.
When we are looking to identify positive
outliers, our ideal case, case number one,
is for sequentially positive, above-sector
average earnings growth momentum.
And when we are also working through our
long-idea processing, we also consider and
identify our case number two and our case
number three.
Now, all of these cases, as you know, we
have identified as optimal situations for
long-idea processing with the ideal being
sequentially positive, above-sector
average earnings growth momentum.
But remember, in these three cases, the
EPS is positive.
We are not coming from a loss-making
situation.
The company is making profit.
So, we have positive EPS and positive
earnings growth in all of those cases.
And this is, of course, evidenced by the
backdrop of the valuation in period two
versus period one.
So, a lower PE in period two versus period
one.
The EPS is going to be higher in period
two.
Therefore, when we take the stock price
today and we divide it by EPS one, the PE
is going to be higher in period one versus
when we take the same stock price of the
current day and divide it by EPS two.
Because EPS two is higher, we're going to
get a lower PE ratio versus PE one.
So, we should always be thinking in terms
of forward-looking fundamentals, earnings
growth momentum, and in terms of price
momentum.
So, we try to concentrate on price and the
fundamentals and valuation that is behind
price and that is driving price.
So, the difference between PE two and PE
one is the gap that the stock needs to go
up to maintain the same PE ratio.
So, it's the price movement from period
one to period two in order to maintain the
same PE in period two as in period one
with the new forecasted EPS.
So, what is happening is the company, when
they're moving from period one to period
two, they are hitting their EPS and
earnings growth percentage guidance.
And by the way, this type of analysis also
applies to PEG ratios.
The difference between PEG two and PEG one
is the amount that the PE ratio has to go
up from period one to period two in order
to maintain the same PEG ratio.
So, this is how we always have to be
thinking about it as traders.
We always want to be thinking in terms of
price momentum and the fundamentals that
are driving the price momentum and the
potential upside over the period.
So, when we are processing for our long
ideas in our quant processing phase and we
are identifying potential long trade
ideas, we want to see really good, strong,
sequentially positive above sector average
earnings growth momentum.
And we also want to see evidence from the
valuation from the PE that the market is
aware of this too and they are paying a
premium for the stock.
Which means if the stock delivers in
period two or in the process of going from
period one to period two, it looks like
increasingly that the stock is going to
deliver on its earnings.
The price is going to close the gap and
the market is going to pay the same or
higher valuation in period two versus
period one.
Now, in terms of processing mechanics for
long ideas, I'm going to hand over now to
Christopher Quill, who's now going to show
you how to get the freely available stock
data.
So, if you recall the stock data that we
were looking at in previous videos, how to
download the data and how to organize it
into a format that's suitable for traders
to identify positive and negative outliers
and shortlisting potential longs and
shorts.
So, Chris is going to show you how to rank
for PE and earnings growth in order to
identify the earnings growth profiles that
we lean towards as traders.
Now, there are downloads for this video in
the downloads area.
I mentioned one previously, which was the
earnings growth profiles for longs
spreadsheet.
You can download that, have a look at the
different earnings growth profiles and
familiarize yourself with all of the
different earnings growth profiles for
longs.
There's also another download, which is
the US sector data spreadsheet, which is
the spreadsheet that Chris is going to
show you how to build and maintain now.
Now, please note, as a side note, this
step does come after something that we
call cleaning the data.
This is something that we're going to
discuss in further PTM videos.
So, I'm going to hand it over to Chris
now.
Enjoy Chris's section of the video.
And I'll see you in the next video when we
are going to start covering short ideas
and we're going to look at the mechanics
of short ideas.
Hi guys, and welcome to another
spreadsheet class.
In this one, what we're going to do is
cover how you can download US stock data
so that you can conduct your initial
quantitative analysts to find outliers
within sectors that could then be
potential long and short ideas subject to
further work, of course.
So, what I'm going to go through is
firstly, how you can find and screen for
US stock data using a free service on
Zaxx.
From there, what we're going to do is
download the screen results and start
cleaning and manipulating the data in
Excel so that we can go through some
analysis steps.
And I'm going to illustrate the process
that you guys should be going through to
find potential ideas and outlier stocks
using examples and commentating on some of
the things that Anton's been talking about
in the presentations as we go.
Hopefully, then you guys are going to have
a good idea of what you need to do going
forward.
Before we start, guys, needless to say,
the stocks and filtering that I'm going to
go through in this video are not
legitimate trade ideas that you can then
put on in your own portfolios once you've
watched the video.
The examples are only there to illustrate
the process that you should be using.
And, you know, of course, the data will be
stale by the time you watch the video
anyway.
And above all else, the steps that we're
going to go through in this video
represent just the very beginning of the
micro analysis process that's required to
generate a legitimate trade idea anyway.
They are by no means they by no means even
represent the process of generating a
fully fledged legitimate trade idea.
It's just identifying outliers.
That's all we're doing in this video.
Remember, guys, there's a whole bunch more
quantitative and qualitative
considerations that you guys need to think
about before even putting a position on as
Anton's already been talking about in the
presentations.
So with that being said, let's get
started.
First things first, we're going to obtain
the data that we need.
And to do that, I'm going to navigate to
zax.com in my web browser.
Then at the top of the page, there's a tab
that you'll see called screening.
And if you hover over that, we're looking
for the stock screener tool, which is the
second one down in the dropdown menu.
And once you select that, it takes you to
Zach's US stock screener tool.
Now, from this stage, we want to start a
new screen, which we do by clicking the
new screen button indicated in the top
left of this table.
And this is where we need to decide on the
criteria of stocks that we want to filter
for within all US equities.
We don't want to add too much here since
we will be filtering the data later in
Excel.
But what we can say for sure is that we're
not really interested in any stocks below
$3 billion in market cap.
Remember, for long positions, we typically
want to stay within the range of $3 to $10
billion.
And for short, we're looking for stocks
with kind of over a $20 billion US dollar
market cap.
So to add a market cap criteria, we just
go down to the market cap option here
within the popular criteria category.
And we want the market cap of the stocks
we retrieve to be greater than or equal to
$3 billion.
So we just need to make sure that the
mathematical operator here is set to
greater than or equal to as it is here.
And then in the next column, we want to
enter the value of 3000.
Now, the reason why we enter 3000 here and
not 3 billion is because we can see that
market cap values in this screen are
denominated in millions.
And so 3000 million is equivalent to 3
billion.
So from there, we just click add to add
the criteria to our screen.
And once that's done, we then need to add
the various columns of data that we want
to be able to see for each stock once we
run the screen.
So here I'm talking about things like
market cap, stock price, earnings and so
on.
To make those additions, you'll need to
click on edit view and start choosing the
various data items that you want within
the different categories running down the
left hand side.
Now I suggest to begin with, you just
follow along with the same criteria that I
choose in this video.
And then you can always expand on that if
and when you feel comfortable to do so.
So working down the categories on the left
hand side, I'm going to start in company
descriptors.
And in there, I'm going to check the boxes
for exchange month and fiscal year end
sector and industry.
Okay.
Those are the data items I want to see for
every single stock.
Then I'm going to go to a different
category, which is the size and share
volume category.
In there, I'm going to make sure that
market cap is already ticked.
We want to know the market cap for every
stock that we're looking at as well.
And that's already ticked because we've
already chosen that as an initial
screening criteria.
So next we'll move on to the price and
price changes category.
In there, I'm just going to check the last
close box, which is basically the last
available daily closing price for each
stock.
Then we move on to EPS surprises and
actuals within that category.
I'm going to select last year's EPS value
F0 and also the last reported fiscal year
for each of these companies.
And then finally, our final category is
going to be EPS estimates.
And in that section, I want to make sure
that we check the boxes for the F1
consensus estimate and F2 consensus
estimate.
Which is basically our forward looking EPS
estimates for each company F1 and F2.
So our current and next fiscal years.
So that's it in terms of the data items
that we're going to add to the screener.
As I said before, as you get more
comfortable with financial data and your
processes as a whole,
you might be able to add in some
additional items at this stage.
But to begin with, this is all you need.
Remember though, it's important not to
consider too many other metrics like
revenue,
growth or backward looking balance sheet
and income state items until you identify
outliers with earnings growth, PE and PEG
ratios.
So don't get caught up with other metrics
too early in the process, even if you do
decide to add them into the screener.
Okay, so let's continue now.
To run the screen and download the data,
all you need to do is hit the run screen
button here.
That opens the screen's results on the
webpage.
And you can see that we've got 2,467
stocks here matching our criteria at this
stage.
And from here to download this data and
open it as an Excel file, you just click
on the CSV button and then open the file.
Now on my setup, I can do this just by
selecting the file that appears at the
bottom of the screen here.
Depending on what your setup is, you might
have to navigate to the downloaded file in
a slightly different way.
But I'll leave that up to you guys.
Alright, so this is what the screen will
initially look like when you open it in
Excel.
And you can see that we've got a little
bit of work here to do first just to tidy
things up and reorganize the data before
we move on to any analysis.
So to begin with, what I'm going to do is
select the whole of row one by clicking
the row index value of one on the left
hand side.
And then choosing to wrap the text in
those cells by navigating to home on the
ribbon and then selecting wrap text.
And you can see now that when the text
sort of wraps to fit within the column
title cells, it's much easier to
understand the data that we're dealing
with.
We can actually read those column titles.
From there, I'm going to reorganize the
column into a different order that makes a
bit more sense.
To move a column, all you need to do is
select it by clicking on the column index
letter and then move your cursor to the
edge of the selection before right
clicking and dragging the column to a
different area.
Then letting go of the right mouse button
and choosing the shift right and move
option.
So here, for example, I'm going to move
the exchange column, the sector column and
industry columns all to the left before
the market cap column.
Then I'm going to move on to the last
reported fiscal year column and move that
before the last close column like this.
And to me, that then all makes a bit more
sense now because from left to right,
we've got our stock names and tickers
followed by the company descriptors, then
fiscal year information and then finally
prices and then earnings.
Okay, so next, what I'm going to do here
is adjust the column widths and row
heights where necessary.
So for each column that needs it, I'm just
going to click and drag its intersection
with the column next to it to expand the
width of that column just so that we can
again read the data in those columns a bit
more easily.
After doing that, I'm then going to reduce
the top row height a little bit and also
make the column headings in bold by
selecting them and pressing control B on
the keyboard.
At this stage, let's go through these
columns of data and actually just make
sure that you guys all understand what
we're looking at here.
So in columns A and B, we've got the
company name and ticker for each stock.
In columns C to E, we have the exchange
the stocks are listed on and then the
sector and industry to which the stocks
belong.
And these sectors and industries are
defined by Zacks.
Column F is the market cap for each
company in millions of dollars.
Then columns G to H are fiscal year
information.
So columns G tells us in which month each
company has their fiscal year end and
where a value of one represents January,
two is February, three is March and so on.
And column H then tells us what the last
fiscal, what the last reported fiscal year
was for each firm, where the number
represents the year followed by the month
in which it ends.
So for example, if we look at Alcoa, the
second stock from the top, we can see that
its fiscal year end is in December each
year.
And the last reported fiscal year was
December 2020.
For reference to you guys, I'm filming
this in October 2021, which will help
explain some of these figures, meaning we
should see companies last reported fiscal
year ends in the spreadsheet up to around
September 2021.
Anyway, in the next column, we've got the
last daily close price for each stock.
And I think I'll rename this column while
we're here and just call it price.
Following that, we have our earnings per
share numbers for each stock where columns
J through L represent the EPS numbers for
the previous fiscal year, the current
fiscal year and the next fiscal year
respectively.
So let's rename those now as well
actually.
So in cell J1, I'm going to rename that
column EPS 0.
In cell K1, I'll rename that column EPS 1.
And likewise in column L, I'll rename the
column EPS 2.
Okay, so that's looking better now.
But before we go on to calculating things
like earnings growth and PE ratios,
there's one more bit of tidying up that we
need to do.
If you take a look at the exchange column,
you'll notice that at the moment we have a
bunch of stocks in this screen that trade
over the counter.
Now, as retail traders, those stocks
aren't really accessible to us.
And so what I'm going to do here is remove
them all from this screen.
To do that, all you need to do is select
any one of the column headings and go to
data on the ribbon, followed by filter
that adds filter options to all of the
columns in our table.
And what we're going to do here is click
on the exchange filter and then deselect
the select all checkbox and then only
check the OTC and OTC BB options and then
press OK.
Once that's done, you can see that it's
returned all of the OTC listings within
our screen.
Now, to delete those items, we can just
select all of the rows that you can see
now and delete them.
And the easiest way to do that is probably
just by clicking the top row here and then
pressing Ctrl Shift and down on the
keyboard if you're on a Windows PC.
And then that selects all of the data down
to the bottom of the sheet.
Then you can just right click within that
selection and go to delete row.
From there, we just need to remove the
filter in the exchange column so that we
can see all of our original data without
the OTC stocks.
And to remove that filter, just select the
filter and go to clear filter from
exchange.
OK, before I forget, now is probably a
good time to remind you that you should
make sure that you save your work as you
go, because these screening sheets that
you create will become pretty important to
your workflow as a trader.
And you're going to want to make sure that
you can access them in the future to
either keep working on the data inside
them or just as a log or reference to
decisions and analysis that you've done in
the past.
Right, let's move on to calculations now.
The calculations that we need to run are
for earnings growth, price earnings ratios
and PEG ratios.
So in columns M2R, I'm going to head the
columns now starting with EG1 in cell M1,
EG2 in cell N1, PE1 in cell O1, PE2 in
cell P1, PEG1 in cell Q1 and finally PEG2
in cell N1.
Then we can make all of those bold just by
selecting them and pressing CTRL B.
So let's move on to the actual
calculations themselves now, beginning in
the earnings growth one column.
In cell M2, the formula that we want to
use for earnings growth for the current
fiscal year is just going to be equals in
brackets K2 minus J2 divided by ABS, the
absolute function.
In Excel in brackets J2.
That's just basically the EPS1 number
minus the EPS0 number divided by the
absolute value of EPS0 and it's important
to make sure that you put the denominator
in the equation into an absolute function
like this so that it's always positive.
The reason being that that helps keep the
signs correct for the output of earnings
growth irrelevant of changing signs in EPS
numbers from year to year.
Don't worry too much if you don't
understand that. Just use this formula and
take my word for it.
After the formula is inputted, we can just
copy it down to the end of the data set in
the usual fashion.
Then for earnings growth two, it's done in
exactly the same way.
And actually we can just copy across the
formula into the next column by selecting
cell M2 and clicking and dragging the
little green box in the bottom right of
the selection to the adjacent cell.
And then we can just copy that formula
down as well.
Moving on to the PE ratio columns now.
In cell O2, the calculation for PE1 is
just the stock price divided by EPS1.
So the formula here is equals I2 divided
by K2.
So our price divided by EPS1.
In cell P2, the calculation is basically
the same for PE2 as it was for PE1, except
that we divide the price by EPS2.
And that gives us the PE ratio for the
next fiscal year rather than the current
fiscal year.
So the formula here is going to be equals
I2 divided by L2.
So with those calculations entered, we can
just copy them down to the end of the data
set and move on to our PEG ratios.
So let's calculate PEG1 now in cell Q2.
The calculation for PEG ratio is just the
PE ratio divided by the earnings growth
expressed as a percentage for the same
fiscal period.
So in this case, the formula would be
equals O2 divided by in brackets M2
multiplied by 100.
We need to multiply the earnings growth
figures we have here by 100 because
currently they're expressed as decimals
and we want them as percentages.
Okay, so now we can do the same for PEG2
numbers in column R.
And as with earnings growth, we can just
copy across the formula that we just
defined for PEG1 into column R.
Remember, though, whenever you do copy
formulas across or down spreadsheets, it's
always best practice to check the results.
In this case, we can see the references
are looking at the PE2 and EG2 values this
time.
And so we know the formula is correct.
Okay, so that's our calculations done now.
But before we move on to looking at a
specific sector and drilling down to find
some potential outliers, let's just format
these calculation columns that we've just
created.
So the earnings growth columns, we can
just format as a percentage to two decimal
places.
And to do that, you can just select the
columns, right click within the selection
and go to format cells and then choose the
percentage category from the options and
allow two decimal places and press OK.
Similarly, I think it's a good idea to
format the PE and PEG ratios as well just
to tidy things up a bit.
And this time I'm just going to format
those as a number to two decimal places by
selecting the columns, right clicking in
the selection, going to format cells.
And then we can just choose the number
category and define two decimal places
followed by OK.
So now that we've got all of the columns
of data that we need, let's go through an
example of how you can find outliers that
represent potential stock ideas going
forward.
Now, remember, guys, I'm saying potential
here for a very good reason, because
finding outliers on their own is not
enough to represent a trade idea.
It's just the beginning of the trade idea
generation process.
Now, in this section, I will primarily be
showing you the process for identifying
outliers on the long side.
But I might also end up referring to a few
things that you're actually still yet to
cover in the video series.
Things like looking at short profiles,
turnarounds and also data mining and
processing mistakes.
Don't worry if you feel like there are
some gaps in your knowledge at this stage.
Just come back and review this video again
after you've completed the quantitative
analysis section of the video series.
So for this example, the industry that
we're going to look at is the medical
dental supplies industry.
And so to begin with, we need to filter
our data for stocks just in that industry.
And to do that, we first need to remove
the previous filter we had by selecting
any column in any column heading rather
and deselecting the filter button in the
data section of the ribbon.
Then straight away, we're going to add it
back again.
And you can see that this time the filters
have applied all the way across our
columns, including the new calculation
columns that we've made.
From here, we want to filter the stocks
that we're looking at by industry.
So that filter that we want to use is the
one in column E.
With the filter option open, we can search
for dental supplies by typing into the
text box here.
And you can see that once you've done
that, once we've typed in dental supplies,
it just returns one industry from our
list, which is the one that we want.
And we can then just press OK.
OK, so here you can see all the US listed
stocks in the dental supplies industry
that come through this screener provided
by Zaxx.
And at this stage, we can start processing
and analyzing the data to find outliers
within the sector.
But one suggestion I have before we start
is actually copying this data into a new
sheet in this file.
The reason being that we want to keep our
original screening sheet clean and free
from any further analysis or annotations.
You can see currently that all the rows
that don't match our industry criteria are
hidden in the left hand sort of row index,
but they still do exist in this sheet.
So any edits or annotations that we do
here will have an effect on the original
data set and we don't want that.
So using a new sheet allows us to kind of
keep things clean.
And it also means that it's going to help
with things like sector calculations and
so on, which we'll get into shortly.
So copying the industry data into its own
sheet is pretty easy.
All you do is just select it all,
including the column headings and then
press control C to copy it.
Then click on the plus button at the
bottom of the spreadsheet to create a new
sheet and then paste it into cell A1 in
the new sheet with control V.
From there, you can also rename this sheet
that we've created to something that
represents the data within it.
So to do that, we can right click the
sheet name at the bottom here and select
rename and then call it something like
dental supplies, for example.
Now, just as we did at the beginning of
the video, we also need to do some
resizing here of some of the columns just
to make it a bit easier to see all of the
data items that we've got.
So I'll just do that now quickly for the
company name and also the sector and
industry columns.
Okay, now we get to move on to the
processing and analytics stage processing
comes first.
And basically what you want to do is make
sure that before anything else is done,
you want to identify and fix any spurious
data.
Now, this stuff comes from video 28 in the
course, but some of the things you'll want
to check for are things like incorrect
earnings data, incorrect calculations,
small earnings numbers leading to very
high magnitude earnings growth figures,
which can then in turn skew sector
calculations and also positive to negative
EPS values and vice versa as you go
through the fiscal years for each company.
Again, that can result in sort of
misleading earnings growth numbers.
So for the purposes of this example, we're
going to assume that all the EPS data we
have here is correct and that we've
checked it.
Therefore, as long as the calculation
formulas we've used previously were
accurate, we should assume that all the
calculation columns are accurate as well.
In terms of spurious data coming from
changes in the signs of earnings or from
small EPS numbers, there isn't too much to
worry about here either.
One thing we might want to keep an eye out
for is the stocks that are showing
particularly high or low earnings growth,
such as Align Technology or Star Surgical
Company.
With Align Technology, there doesn't seem
to be too much wrong with the EPS figures
at first sight, but potentially with Star
Surgical, the earnings growth in the
current fiscal year is getting skewed
upwards by a particularly low EPS number.
Now, whether or not this affects your
analysis will come down to you doing a
little bit extra work and using some
common sense, you'll probably want to find
out whether the EPS numbers are
particularly strange or out of line in the
context of the stock's previous numbers.
And if they are, then it might be worth
excluding them from things like sector
averages, which actually we're going to
move on to calculating just now.
So I'm going to run these in row 17.
So in cell A17, I'm going to title the row
sector averages.
And then in cell M17, I'm going to
calculate the average EG1 number for the
sector.
The formula for that is just going to be
equals average.
So we're using the XL average function
here, and then in brackets, selecting
cells M2 to M15.
From there, you can just copy across that
formula to calculate the sector averages
for EG2, PE1, PE2, PEG1 and PEG2, because
they all use a very similar formula.
We're just changing the references here.
So you can see that when I do that, there
are some formatting issues for the PE and
PEG numbers, just because when we copied
across the formula,
we also copied across the percentage
formatting from the EG1 or earnings growth
one column.
So to rectify that, I'm just going to
select cells O17 to R17 and format them as
numbers to two decimal places.
Okay, so running through these figures
now, our sector averages are 44.06% for
EG1, 8.36% for EG2, 34.57 for PE1, 30.73
for PE2, 1.58 for PEG1 and 2.55 for PEG2.
Now, remember what I said earlier
regarding keeping an eye on data that
might be skewing sector averages.
If we take a look at this sector just by
eye, we can see that if anything, the only
sort of potential spurious data that's
having an outsized effect on sector
averages is Star Surgical Company.
We can see this just by looking at things
like its EG1 number and PE ratios, which
are much, much higher than the rest of the
sector.
Now, as I said earlier, this could be due
to the law of small numbers, meaning that
the EPS numbers we see are relatively
small,
which then causes very large calculation
figures when those small numbers are used
as denominators of equations such as in
the EG1 and PE ratios.
One thing we can do at this stage is just
test the effect of Star Surgical on the
sector averages to get a better idea of
what's going on.
And probably the simplest way to do that
with EG1, for example, is just by deleting
the company's numbers and seeing how much
the sector average changes.
And you can see here when we clear the
contents of the EG1 value for Star
Surgical that the sector average decreases
pretty significantly by around 7%.
So it goes from 44% to 37%.
The same can be seen in the PE ratios as
well.
When Star Surgical's PEs are removed from
the sector, the sector average for PE1,
for example, reduces from about 34% to 25%
and for PE2 from 30% to 23%.
Now, I'm not saying for sure that you
should definitely be removing these
numbers from the process.
What I am saying is that you need to look
out for data like this and use common
sense to tackle any issues that it might
cause.
With, of course, the help from Anton in
video 28, which you'll be going through
later.
If you think these numbers cause
unacceptable skew in our sector averages,
then you can modify the sector averages by
calculating them without Star Surgical,
for example.
Or potentially you could use a different
measure of centrality for the data, for
the sector data, such as using the median
function, for example.
But you can only really do that with
sectors that have a decent number of
stocks within them.
Modifying the sector averages matters
because, remember, they're used to help
identify sector outliers to then do
further analysis on.
So for the purposes of this example, I'm
going to leave Star Surgical's data in,
but just take a mental note of the effect
that it's having as we go forward.
Now, we don't have an example of this in
this sector, but another thing to watch
out for is EPS values that change sign
from year to year and what that kind of
means for earnings growth as well.
Now, as Anton will show you in video 28,
one of the ways to tackle wild earnings
growth figures caused by EPS changing from
positive to negative and vice versa is
just to cap the growth or loss at 100%.
Now, I'm not going to go into that here.
But you are going to learn about that in
video 28.
And if you're looking at a sector with
those issues, all you would need to do is
write over the earnings growth numbers
with whatever is relevant.
So plus or minus 100%.
Okay.
So just before I go into looking at some
of the stocks here in more detail to
identify outliers and various sort of long
or short profiles, there is one more
important thing to note at this stage,
which is actually pretty relevant for this
sector.
And that is the fact that a lot of these
companies have quite different fiscal year
ends.
Now, this is pretty rare, to be honest,
but you can see here in this example
sector that we've got fiscal years ending
in September, December, June, October,
March and April.
And the reason why we need to kind of pay
attention to that is that obviously it has
an impact on how we view the earnings and
valuation numbers for each stock.
So for context, I'm filming this in
October 2021.
That means that a stock like Amerisource
Virgin, for example, has just reported
their previous fiscal year, which ended in
September.
Now that means their current fiscal year
numbers are effectively forward looking by
about 11 months since their current fiscal
year ends in September 2022.
Compare that to, for example, Align
Technology, whose fiscal year ends in
December.
Their current fiscal year only has around
two to three months remaining.
And so the weight that we should put on
that current fiscal year compared to the
next fiscal year numbers is much less than
for Amerisource,
which is just something to bear in mind.
Remember also that when Align reports in
January or February, a month or two after
their fiscal year end,
their numbers are going to shift from
left, from right to left in this sheet.
Meaning assuming expectations are 100%
accurate and remain constant going forward
until that point,
their current year numbers will become
their previous year numbers and their next
year figures will become their current
year values and so on.
Okay. So hopefully that's all clear.
I'm just trying to be kind of thorough for
you guys at this point to kind of let you
know what you should be looking out for
and the kind of thought processes that you
should be going through when looking at
data like this and analyzing it.
Let's move on to identifying some outliers
now then, starting with looking for
potential long ideas.
To begin with, we want to find stocks
where the market is paying a premium for
earnings,
which essentially means that the market
thinks the quality of the stock's earnings
is high.
Doing that's pretty simple.
All we need to do is filter the sector for
above average PE numbers.
So to start with, let's add a filter to
the data by selecting any column title and
going to data on the ribbon and then
filter.
From there, let's start with PE1 and
select the filter and choose number
filters.
And then above average, which will filter
the sector to only show stocks with above
average PE1 figures.
And you can see those stocks here.
So we've got Align, Conmed, Star and West
Pharmaceutical.
We can then do the same thing with PE2 as
well.
And you can see that by adding a PE2
filter in this case, it doesn't actually
make that much difference.
But there will be, of course, definitely
times when you're doing this sort of
analysis and that will narrow down the
stocks that you're looking at further.
So we've now got a good idea of the stocks
in a sector where the market is paying a
premium for their earnings.
What we now want to do is look at earnings
growth.
And ideally, we would like to see above
average, sequentially higher earnings
growth figures across the current and next
fiscal year for our long outliers.
But we can see here just by eyeballing the
stocks that we have that that particular
profile doesn't exist.
But we might have the next best thing,
which is above sector average earnings
growth in both the current and the next
fiscal year.
So we can add some more filters in the
same way as we did before.
But this time for earnings growth columns
rather than the PE columns.
Well, I should say as well as the PE
columns, because we're going to keep those
filters that we've already used thus far.
So I'm going to add an above average
filter for both the EG1 and EG2 columns
here and we'll see what happens to our
results.
So as you can see here, that leaves us
with three stocks.
We've got Align, Conmed and Star Surgical
remaining.
There's still a couple more things that we
should be doing to make sure that we end
up identifying stocks are worth doing some
extra work on at this stage.
Firstly, remember, we're looking for
potential long ideas here.
And if we have a look at the market cap
column, we can see that Align technology
has a market cap that is actually well
above the cutoff that we should have for
long positions, which is about $10
billion.
So we can rule that one out straight away.
And it's also worth looking at PE ratios
to check that the numbers kind of confirm
that the stock's earnings are good
quality.
So they should be kind of in line with
what we see in the PE columns.
Typically, this isn't as important as
looking at the PE ratios, but it's still a
good sign to see PE numbers above one for
our last two stocks, which are Conmed and
Star Surgical.
So like I said, that's just another
verification that the market deems that
the earnings for these companies are high
quality.
So that's probably as far as we need to
go, really, for identifying potential long
idea outliers in this sector.
Conmed and Star Surgical would both now
require extra work if we were kind of
doing this for real, both on the
quantitative and qualitative side of
things before going any further.
And only if everything then checks out
could we possibly think about using them
as trade ideas.
One thing I do want to note here with the
process that we've used is, you know, at
the beginning, I obviously chose to keep
Star Surgical in the analysis.
It might be that actually if we did a
little bit more digging and more work when
we looked at the company's past earnings,
we could come to the conclusion that
actually the low EPS numbers are outliers
for Star Surgical and it is skewing the
sector data.
And therefore, we could exclude Star
Surgical from the analysis and redo the
stages that we went through just now.
And that in turn might then result in an
extra one or two potential stocks to
conduct further analysis on.
And, you know, these are the kind of
decisions and thoughts that you guys are
going to have to kind of go through.
And they're going to require, you know,
your own logic and common sense to do so
that isn't necessarily going to be a
correct answer.
Again, all I'm kind of trying to do here
when I'm talking about this stuff is
getting you thinking about the processing
and analysis stages in the right way so
that you can make your own informed
decisions.
So before we finish here, let's quickly
take the filters off again and just see if
we can identify any other stocks that
might be of interest in this sector.
And to do that, I'm just going to select
each filter in turn and choose the option
in each one to clear the filter for that
column.
Okay, so I'm just going to be eyeballing
here.
We're not going to go into any level of
detail, like I say, because you've kind of
got more things to cover in the video
series, but the processes are going to be
very similar to what we've just covered
with long only ideas.
So like I said, I'm just eyeballing here,
but I can see that, for example, both
Laboratory Corporation of America and
McKesson Corporation have declining
earnings growth profiles, which might make
them interesting short candidates as they
could be ex growth stocks.
And they also have below sector average P
ratios and market caps above $20 billion.
So that fits some of our other
requirements as well.
You guys are going to learn more about
shorts in the subsequent videos, but yeah,
those two could potentially be
interesting.
Another one that could be interesting,
although this is a little bit of a stretch
is Cardinal Health.
It's earnings growth and valuation numbers
aren't particularly far off what could be
considered a potential turnaround story or
value trap.
So a deeper dive into what's going on
there could also yield some pretty
exciting conclusions as well.
Now, like I said, I'm not going to talk
about shorts or value traps and
turnarounds in any more detail, really,
because you guys are going to be covering
those in subsequent videos.
But I did just want to kind of highlight
and reference them here because ultimately
the process that you're going to go
through to identify them will be very
similar to the process that we use to
identify longs.
You know, meaning downloading all of the
US stock data, getting your industry data
copied across into a new sheet, cleaning
all the data and then using filters in the
various columns to get to the results that
you want.
The ones that you're looking for.
So whether you're looking for long
profiles, short profiles or potentially
turnarounds or value traps, things like
that.
OK, guys, that's it for this one. As I
said, it's just a short tutorial to show
you how to practically implement the first
stage of your micro analysis after you've
built up a macro picture.
Remember, this really is just the first
stage, though, and once you've been
through this, you'd then need to go into a
much deeper dive into quantitative
analysis using other metrics like revenue
growth and all the backward looking
balance sheet and income statement metrics
as well.
Then after all of that, you also need to
understand the stock story and conduct a
qualitative assessment as well.
And only once you've done all of that can
the idea actually become a trade.
You've probably realized as I've been
through this section of the video that
nothing is black and white when it comes
to micro analysis, even on the
quantitative side.
It's going to require sort of logic, due
diligence and above all common sense in
order to get to sensible conclusions.
So remember to stick to your ITPM
principles when you're doing this work.
It isn't possible for us to do all of the
work for you.
You're going to have to be able to deal
with various real world problems whenever
you're dealing with data and analyzing
stocks.
Don't get overwhelmed.
Just stick your head down and get on with
it and you're going to reap the rewards
for it later.
All right, guys, that's it for this one.
And I'll see you later in the video
series.
in the video series.